illustrated book for children celebrates
the rich achievements and Legacy of
black and brown people throughout
history it's called we are here it's a
follow-up to the New York Times
best-selling book all because you matter
the book's creators best-selling author
Tammy Charles an award-winning
illustrator Brian Collier are here with
us good morning Happy New Year happy New
Year good to see you congratulations on
this book
um Tammy this is your second book we
just talked about the first all because
you matter talk to me about the
inspiration for this one so we are here
is inspired by the first book all
because you matter stand alone but
they're definitely connected
um I I wrote All Because you matter
because my son had he was in
kindergarten and he had learned about Dr
King and he couldn't understand why they
treated him so unfairly
fast forward to the pandemic we saw a
rise of Injustice against people of
color so my son came back he had more
questions and that's when I realized I
wasn't done yet I needed to write
something that really
honored and celebrated our history
across the globe so we are here is
inspired by these conversations with my
son but there's a dedication of this
book to your daughter who you say you
never got to meet how did she Inspire
this book
so during these conversations when the
pandemic hit
um it made me think of the child that I
lost years ago and I wondered what would
I have said to my child my daughter if
she had the same questions as
Christopher my son
and I realized I would have taught her
about the Legacy the rich Legacy from
which she comes so in the book you'll
see Brian did such an incredible job
there's a pink balloon
follows our character all throughout the
story that's Grace but it's also a
gentle reminder that we are here for a
reason and to make a an impact on the
whole globe it's beautiful thank you I
um gosh I have so many questions but
Brian it's gorgeous it's just a
beautiful book and I think sometimes
when parents are reading to their kids
as I do you know you're reading to them
you're conveying an important message or
you're reading a fun story but then
you're holding art in your hands this is
just true art how did you break into
this how did you come into illustrate I
know people who are like I'd love to
Illustrated children's book I love the
writer children's book How do you how do
you get into it I was I was making art
at age 15. and which is sort of late but
uh in terms of illustration I went door
to door to every major publisher in New
York City once a week with a portfolio
trying to get a book deal and finally
somebody said yes we're simple hustle
yes once a week once a week oh that's
inspiring that's your next book yeah
Tammy you talk about the importance of
legacy and teaching young children all
children but especially children of
color the important lineage that they
come from you used to be a teacher yes
was was that something that you felt
your students needed to know or were
missing from their understanding of of
themselves their history and also what
did how did your students inspire you to
write your first book
so growing up I really didn't see myself
in a lot of the books that I read and
always loved reading but a lot of the
characters didn't represent who I was or
where I came from I was born in Newark
New Jersey
um fast forward to when I became a
teacher there were definitely more
diverse Books available I I read these
stories with my students stories from
Kwame Alexander and Meg Medina
Jacqueline Woodson and together we would
write our own and my students said you
should become an author so they kind of
gave me the green light and I've been
doing this ever since I've I write for
them yeah so it was the students that
said oh yeah I I wanted to be an author
I just didn't think I could you know
representation is everything so I was
happy to add my voice to the new or more
diverse Canon of literature now and you
know this comes as there's a big debate
in a lot of States about banning certain
kinds of books or what is appropriate
for schools and libraries right now did
that have any influence over the
creation of this one
absolutely so like I said when I was a
child I just didn't see a lot of diverse
books one of my favorite uh leaders in
this industry is Dr rudine Sims Bishop
she says books should serve as Windows
Doors and mirrors for me as a former
teacher I think that's a way to teach
our children empathy and respect and
what better way to do that than to write
books so in the face of these book bands
I'm going to keep writing because I'm
writing for them let me ask you Brian
just really quickly about your art
because it is so beautiful I wonder if
the audience can see this I mean I just
wanted to understand your style you're
showing here a young girl I love the
hair but she's blowing bubbles and then
there are these this this planets these
planets these stars
um the the wood behind her is incredible
how do you like what is this style where
does it come from it's watercolor and
collage combined I was inspired by my
grandmother making quilts when I was a
kid so when you look at the artwork it's
the influence of a quilt maker you can
see that on the work yes it's absolutely
lovely uh Tammy Charles Brian Collier
thank you so much for being here this
book's incredible it's called we are
here it is available tomorrow wherever
you like to buy your books
congratulations happy New Year taking
one of these home for my daughter I'll
be right back